that's just that's years of practice
together and those guys were clicking
yesterday and we needed it
because they made some huge plays down
the stretch obviously you know it was
apparent on those two touchdown catches
that's Matt Lafleur coach to the Packers
talking about the performance of
quarterback Aaron Rodgers and receiver
Davante Adams Adams had 160 receiving
yards in the game some big catches some
key catches and and Rodgers and Adams
are at a point where they just know they
don't need to speak it they know where
each other will be they know where the
ball will be Rodgers knows where Adams
will be
Peter it's an amazing thing to see and
you spoke to the floor after the game
you're actually in Green Bay for the
game
Donte Adams had a big catch late a key
catch late that helped cement that
victory what went down on that play
Michael was a third and eight play
basically two minutes to go and the
Green Bay Packers knew that if they gave
if they didn't convert on this third
down that they were obviously gonna be
giving the ball back to Russell Wilson
in very good field position maybe let's
say it his 30 or 35 with two timeouts
left and what made this great is that
Aaron Rodgers audible to this play he
stunned Matt Lafleur Lafleur thought he
knew exactly what they were gonna do in
other words basically where where he did
the double move coming out of that break
he thought that they were just going to
make the throw to get the first down and
to move the chains
but Rodgers saw something in a young
defensive back on the Seahawks that he
thought he could beat and it's great
because if you watched this play this
happened right in front of Matt Lafleur
and he said well I guess Aaron changed
the call and the reason that Lafleur
could laugh about it remember all the
controversy preseason about the fact
oh my god Lafleur doesn't want Rodgers
to audible Rodgers is concerned about
not being able audible all this stuff
Mike silver wrote about it and the great
thing about this play and I can tell you
the
Matt Lafleur was laughing about it after
the game like well Aaron saw something
and I and I asked him about it he said I
want Aaron to control the field I want
him to be able to make decisions like
that and Mike a guy who can throw the
ball as perfectly as Aaron Rodgers would
do I would want to take advantage of
that institutional knowledge you know
it's funny there was a similar moment in
week 15 against the Chicago Bears where
I had a similar conversation with Matt
Lafleur after the game similar moment
facing a fourth down they were just
gonna try to move the sticks and get the
first down and Aaron saw something as
LeFleur said and decided to call the
audible touchdown pass to Davante Adams
and Lafleur said at the time look Aaron
can do whatever he wants and that's the
smart play that's the mark of a good
coach he comes in there with an offense
that is very structured very regimented
has very limited discretion for the
quarterback and that was part of the
back-and-forth that really came to life
in the Mike Silver column and anybody
who says that issue was overblown wasn't
paying attention
it wasn't overblown it was an issue
there was a conflict between the Matt
Lafleur offense and the way Aaron
Rodgers wanted to play quarterback and
Rodgers helped get it public help start
the discussion and the end result is
Aaron Rodgers can do what he wants and
the Packers are 14 and 3 playing for a
berth in the Superbowl so they did the
right thing in giving him the ability to
change the play whenever he wants we saw
it in the regular season and Peter you
saw it on and heard about it from
Lafleur on Sunday Mike there's one
little asterisk about this story that I
absolutely love a month ago when I spent
time with Mike McCarthy and we were
talking about Rodgers he told me an
incredible story that at some point I'm
gonna write I just it's gonna take a
while to develop it but in 2014 Andrew
Aaron Rodgers threw a touchdown pass
against the Detroit Lions in which he
audibled twice at the line of scrimmage
not once twice and the second one was
with about eight seconds to go beyond
the
on the play clock and to do that on the
road so that all 10 guys hear it and
understand it and then to throw a
touchdown that is the genius of Aaron
Rodgers yeah and you know Mike McCarthy
got hired by the Dallas Cowboys and look
Peter I I can understand what the
Cowboys did it I think that Jerry Jones
the owner of the Cowboys could very
easily look at his team's over the past
10 years
McCarthy's teams over the past 10 years
and come to the conclusion that McCarthy
did more with lesser talent overall ah
but put man the first year after Mike
McCarthy to see this team at 14 and 3 I
tell you why I know there's plenty of
factors that go into it but but yeah if
I'm a Cowboys fan I'm a little nervous
I'm a little nervous about what the
Packers are bitin the flames McCarthy
there's plenty of factors there's plenty
of factors and two of them are named
Smith so you know this is a better
defense
I believe overall since any year the
Packers have played since the Super Bowl
you know in that Super Bowl season they
have the rookie clay Mathews and they
have the veteran Charles Woodson and
those guys were dominant players you
know on the line of scrimmage and in the
secondary and now for the first time
they've got two dominant pass rushers
for the first time in a you know on any
Packers team that I remembered in recent
recent years that is what is making all
the difference and think about what that
means for McCarthy who for years had to
deal with Ted Thompson as the GM who
would do nothing in free agency it was
all built through the draft built
through the draft built through the
draft he's got a guy in Jerry Jones
Stephen Jones and the rest of that front
office they're willing to go out and do
what needs to be done they're trying to
make the team better that they're not
trying to force it only through the
draft so that helps McCarthy and Peter
the other thing that helps McCarthy I
don't know if we talked about this last
week but the idea that he had all those
years without an owner in Green Bay and
you can get complacent and that's what
Mark Murphy said the CEO of the team at
the press conference regarding the
decision to move on from Mike McCarthy
there will be no complacency in Dallas
would Jer
Jones constantly hanging around and
Stephen Jones constantly hanging around
and I think it could work very well for
the Cowboys and for the Packers Post
Mike McCarthy in Green Bay and with Mike
McCarthy in Dallas you know Mike I think
that's a good point but I can tell you
one other thing from spending time with
McCarthy that and I have not talked to
him about this since he's gotten the job
but it occurs to me one of the things
that really bothered Mike McCarthy when
he was the coach of the Packers is that
no matter what happened he was the guy
who had to address it Ted Thompson was
reticent shy whatever you'd call him he
hated talking to the press he didn't
mind I when I go into Green bad always
be able to talk to Ted Thompson but it
would be just a conversation it would
not be an interview and that is what
kind of drove McCarthy crazy because
stuff that he had nothing to do with he
had to stand up there and speak for the
organization and when we were talking
about this we were talking about all
these different jobs I said well if for
some reason you go to Dallas you
absolutely won't have to worry about
that
you'll probably be wanting to talk more
for the organization rather than however
much you do talk and that's a good point
but the other side of it some of the
things that Jerry Jones says can create
problems for Mike McCarthy because there
was plenty of course this year that
created issues for Jason Garrett and
confusion in the locker room and
sometimes well Jason Garrett's saying
during his mandatory press conferences
conflicts with what Jerry Jones has said
but that's just part of being the Dallas
Cowboys they always give us something to
consider and to dissect right you also
spoke to Derrick Henry who was the star
of Saturday night in Baltimore what
stood out from you based upon your
conversation with the first man in NFL
history to rush for 180 or more yards in
three straight games first of all Mike
Derrick Henry detests talking about
himself he hates it
it's he's almost derisively answers a
question about his own accomplishments
he just he he can't stand it it is all
about the team and now I've talked to
him two times this year and
about the exact same message and
everybody on that team around that team
believes it's absolutely real but what
was fun talking to him the other night
he's got the biggest kick out of
throwing the jump pass you know here's a
guy who was in junior high school and a
football fan when he would watch Tim
Tebow doing this at Florida and the
other thing that was so cool about this
look who he beat on this past he threw
the ball too high for Earl Thomas to do
anything about it so Derrick Henry who
one day might be making a speech in
Canton I bet he's gonna say hey for the
only touchdown pass I ever threw in my
career I beat a hall-of-famer hey it may
not be the only one there may be more
the way he delivered that one and it's
funny he had Marcus Mariota wide open
down on the right sideline it was it's
just it's just that's amazing that's the
kind of creativity that confidence in
your offense breeds because everything's
clicking we can do something different
because they are bearing embracing for
of that Smash Mouth style when you are
Smash Mouth over and over and over again
the last thing they expect is a trick
play and now this week the Chiefs are
going to have to expect the possibility
that they may have some other trick up
their sleeve
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports